luego un año de trabajo la convención
constitucional chilena entrega al
presidente Gabriel borich en la
propuesta de una nueva Carta Magna que
será votada en un plebiscito en el
próximo 4 de septiembre tras esta
entrega que termina con la disolución de
la Constituyente comienza entonces en
Chile un período de dos meses donde la
ciudadanía deberá tomar posición ante
dos alternativas quienes aprueban este
texto y quienes lo rechazan el escenario
es incierto en un referendo que tendrá
voto obligatorio cuando en Chile el
sufragio es voluntario por lo que
resulta una incógnita Hacia dónde
inclinarán la balanza los más de 15
millones de chilenos convocados a las
urnas para analizar entonces lo que
ocurre en Chile en cuanto a la
Constitución la entrega de esta nueva
Carta Magna el presidente Boris Y qué va
a pasar en las elecciones en septiembre
podemos hablar con Marta lagos analista
internacional economista y directora de
la encuesta regional latino latino
barómetro gracias a Marta por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 muy buena mañana le pregunta Entonces
qué contiene esta nueva constitución que
es lo más nuevo o lo más radicalmente
cambiado digámoslo Así que podemos
encontrar
bueno encontramos solamente un 23% que
proviene de constituciones chilenas
anteriores y aquí se cambia el régimen
político se cambia la política
medioambiental
aparece la política hacia los pueblos
originarios y hay una gran cantidad de
los 388 artículos que están dedicados a
los garantías sociales la garantías
sociales constituyeron el corazón de la
demanda de la protesta del año 19
pero lo que ha estado en en la mira y en
la controversia es todos los artículos
referentes a los pueblos originarios y
al sistema político principalmente
además de los cambios que se produjeron
en el sistema de Justicia que es lo que
está produciendo la mayor cantidad de
rechazo porque la polémica Marta en esta
reformas de los pueblos originarios
bueno la polémica es porque hay mucha
gente que opina dentro del establishment
más tradicional que opina que sea la
entregado demasiado derechos no que se
declaró que chile era un estado
plurinacional y que esta
plurinacionalidad
dividiría la nación asunto que no queda
establecido en la constitución pero esa
es el argumento que dan lo que lo que no
les gusta la plurinacionalidad y el
exceso de
privilegios Se podría decir porque se
crea una instancia judicial
especial para los pueblos originarios
además de la justicia regular no Por lo
tanto los pueblos originarios estarían
rigiendo por su propia sus propias
reglas digamos de tradicionales dentro
de jueces que estarían nominados
específicamente para esas
cosas Marta que dicen que dicen los
sondeos que tan dividido está el pueblo
chileno y sobre todo el electorado en
cuanto a la aprobación o el rechazo de
esta nueva constitución que como ya lo
dijimos se va a votar el próximo 4 de
septiembre
esto tiene varias aristas No porque se
supone que esta elecciones con voto
obligatorios sobre los 15 millones de
personas que votan entonces lo primero
que hay que hacer hay que calcular
cuánta gente va a ir a votar nosotros
calculamos la semana pasada una encuesta
que votarían alrededor de 10 millones es
decir más o menos dos millones dos
millones y medio más de lo que vota
regularmente en la última elección
presidencial pero no nunca van a llegar
a una cifra muy demasiado superior a eso
Entonces es un Esto va a ser una
votación con una participación electoral
muy superior a la regular pero no va a
llegar a los 12 o 13 o 14 millones que
el legislador A lo mejor imaginó cuando
dictó esta ley porque llevamos un
régimen de Voto voluntario ya durante
una década y ese se reproduce ese
comportamiento electoral sin que en la
multa del voto obligatorio sea un
castigo real el chile hoy día nadie
obedece una ley lo que hay aquí es
precisamente el problema de la autoridad
del estado y por lo tanto la multa no es
no significa una amenaza importante para
nadie ese poco creíble que el estado en
su debilidad que está sea capaz de
imponer de de ejecutar la multa a todos
los que no van a ir a votar no no no
nadie cree eso claro Marta y al día de
hoy le pregunto si ya los chilenos
tienen una decisión Clara en cuanto a su
votación o hay muchos indecisos hasta
ahora bueno entre los 10 millones que
dicen que van a ir a votar el resultado
sería 32 puntos para el 38 puntos para
la prueba y 42 puntos para el rechazo
llevado al 100% de eso es un resultado
de 48 52 más o menos es decir hay una
hay una ventaja importante de cuatro
puntos a favor del del rechazo pero la
campaña empieza Hoy No hoy día se
entrega la Constitución y entonces
empieza digamos toda la la campaña
oficial si uno quiere
y con el texto definitivo yo creo que
este es el punto más bajo que va a tener
en la prueba en este momento hay una
crítica muy muy alta a la convención
constitucional que ha producido todo
tipo de polémicas a mi juicio
innecesaria porque son polémicas que no
tienen que ver con el texto sino que
tienen que ver con la actitud y la los
comportamientos de la de los miembros de
la convención y
la gente de la pruebo espera que al irse
la convención porque iría deja de
existir el el poder Constituyente y pasa
a manos del poder constituido en esa
medida se piensa que esas actitudes
negativas van a tener menos peso en el
futuro y van a poder convocar a
importante para que vayan a votar porque
los indecisos son solo 9%. entonces La
verdad es que no hay mucho espacio entre
los indecisos Sí hay mucho espacio entre
aquellos que aún no han decidido llegar
a la urna el que llega a la urna y por
eso no hay indecisos no llega indeciso
llega con un voto decidido acá el cuando
cuando uno se mete en la discusión se
polariza Entonces tenemos a 10 millones
de personas polarizadas entre la prueba
y el rechazo y tenemos a 5 millones de
que no no tan polarizadas no están
participando no no dicen si si quiere no
lo quieren y en eso consiste la campaña
Pues bueno Marta todo está sobre la mesa
vamos a ver entonces cómo se desarrollan
estos dos meses de campaña Y qué va a
pasar el próximo 4 de septiembre cuando
finalmente el oso chilenos esos 10
millones aproximadamente que usted dijo
que pueden ir a las urnas Entonces por
qué se decide si aprobar esta nueva
Carta Magna o obviamente rechazarla y
pues por supuesto tenemos un análisis
con el resultado que tengamos ese día o
al día siguiente Gracias Marta como